aquí tengo tres relaciones distintas
entre keys y jay y quiero pensar en cuál
de estas y es que la hay es una relación
proporcional y después quiero graficar
la xi a partir de su gráfica a ver si la
relación es proporcional
ahora como recordatorio una relación
proporcional es una relación en la que
la razón entre dos variables digamos que
tomó la razón entre jay x aunque también
podría ser la razón entre xy la razón
entre ley x siempre será algún número k
una constante k o podrías escribirlo de
otra manera si multiplicamos ye sobre x
igual acá si multiplicamos ambos lados
de esta ecuación por x podrías decir que
la relación proporcional
igual acá x que siempre será igual
alguna constante k por equis y bueno ya
dicho esto veamos estas relaciones
veamos aquí esta primera relación voy a
dibujar otra columna esta columna es la
columna de 10 sobre x ahora vamos a
averiguar cuál es la razón para cada uno
de estos pares
entonces para el primer par cuando x es
igual a 1 y es igual a un medio tenemos
un medio sobre 1 eso es simplemente un
medio
ahora cuando x es igual a 4 y es igual a
entonces esta razón será igual a 2 sobre
4 eso es igual a un medio
y cuando x es igual a menos 2 y es igual
a menos 1 esta razón es igual a menos 1
sobre menos 2 lo cual es lo mismo que un
medio así que por lo menos para estos
primeros 3 puntos de esta relación
parece ser que la razón entre jay x
siempre es un medio entonces en este
caso k será igual a un medio entonces
escribo que sobre x es igual a un medio
que sobre x siempre será igual a un
medio o al menos para estos primeros
tres puntos que tomamos como muestra
podemos pensar que siempre es en el caso
que la relación entre x siempre será
igual a un medio ahora si lo quieres
escribir de otra manera también podrías
escribir y igual a un medio por x
ahora vamos a graficar entonces tenemos
aquí cuando x es igual a 1
y es igual a un medio así que cuando x
es igual a 1 y es igual a un medio
cuando x es igual a 4 y es igual a 2 acá
está x igual a 4 cuando x es igual a 4 y
es igual a 2 aquí está el punto y cuando
x es igual a menos 2 y es igual a menos
1 aquí está el tercer punto ahora
observa si tomamos estos 3 puntos como
una muestra de toda la relación y en
toda la relación tenemos que es igual a
un medio por x entonces el conjunto de
todos los puntos que representan los
pares xy sería una línea que pasa por el
origen tendríamos entonces una línea una
línea así que pasa por el origen porque
observa que si x es igual a 0 un medio
por 0 es igual a ye ahora pensemos en
algunas de las características
principales en primer lugar
esta es una línea es una relación lineal
y en segundo lugar también pasa por el
origen lo cual tiene mucho sentido
porque es una relación proporcional
aunque si lo vemos aquí tenemos la forma
indeterminada tendríamos 0 entre 0
entonces ahí se pone un poco raro pero
cuando ves esto si x es igual a 0 y lo
multiplicas por alguna constante
entonces ya también será igual a cero
así que en cualquier relación
proporcional cuando x es igual a cero se
debe cumplir que también jesse igual a
cero y si traza su gráfica tendrás una
línea que pasa por el origen aquí
tenemos el origen entonces esta es una
relación proporcional donde su gráfica
está representada por una línea que pasa
por el origen ahora ahora veamos esta
segunda relación
pensemos en si esta relación es
proporcional podríamos hacer lo mismo
calcular la razón entre x entonces pongo
otra columna para que sobre x
para esta primera pareja tendríamos 3
sobre 1 entonces tenemos aquí 3 sobre 1
lo cual es igual a 3 aquí tendríamos 5
sobre 2 y 5 sobre 2 no es lo mismo que 3
entonces desde aquí ya sabemos que esta
relación no es proporcional lo escribo
no proporcional esta relación no es
proporcional no proporcional de hecho
aquí ya ni siquiera necesitamos ver este
último punto donde si tomamos la razón
tendríamos menos 1 sobre menos 1 eso es
igual a 1 pero sólo por diversión vamos
a graficar esto entonces cuando x es
igual a 1 y es igual a tres cuando x es
igual a 2 y es igual a 5 y cuando x es
igual a menos 1 que es igual a menos 1
ahora supongamos que damos el beneficio
de la duda
y pensemos que estos puntos podrían ser
tres puntos de una línea porque parece
ser que los puedo conectar una línea
entonces la línea se mira
y así ahora nota que esto es lineal esta
es una línea pero no pasa por el origen
entonces si solo estás analizando una
relación de manera visual lineal es
bueno pero necesita pasar por el origen
para que sea una relación proporcional y
de hecho lo puedes ver aquí esta es una
relación lineal o al menos para estos
tres puntos su gráfica es una línea que
pasa por el origen esta es una relación
lineal pero en esta gráfica la línea no
pasa por el origen y aquí podemos ver en
las razones que en efecto no es una
relación proporcional entonces esto es
no proporcional ahora veamos este último
ejemplo veamos si esta última relación
es proporcional veamos que tenemos aquí
veamos las razones entonces agregó
agregó la columna de ye sobre x y para
el primer renglón tenemos 1 sobre 1 eso
es igual a 1 entonces 1 sobre 1 es igual
a 1
luego tenemos 4 sobre 2 es igual a 2
inmediatamente vemos que esta no es una
relación proporcional ahora 9 sobre 3 es
igual a 3 entonces claramente aquí no
tenemos un número constante
no tenemos siempre el mismo valor así
que esto tampoco es proporcional así que
pongo no proporcional pero bueno graphic
hemos lo sólo por diversión así que
vamos vamos a graficar esta relación
entonces cuando x es igual a 1 y es
igual a 1 cuando x es igual a 2 y es
igual a 4 aquí tenemos que igual a 4 de
hecho esto se parece la gráfica de ye
igual a x al cuadrado
ahora cuando x es igual a 3 y es igual a
9 entonces si estos tres puntos salen de
una muestra de igual a x al cuadrado
tenemos que cuando x es igual a 0
también es igual a 0 así que esta
gráfica
si pasa por el origen porque cuando x es
igual a 0 y es igual a 0 pero nota que
esta gráfica no es una línea la voy a
trazar así que esta gráfica de ye igual
a x al cuadrado no es una línea no es
una línea pero pasa por el origen así
que no es una relación lineal por lo
tanto tampoco es una relación
proporcional entonces una vez más estos
tres puntos son muestras de ye igual a
un medio por equis y en la segunda
relación tenemos que estos tres puntos
podrían ser la muestra de veamos parece
una línea la línea llegue igual a 2 x +
entonces es una relación lineal pero no
pasa por el origen por lo tanto no es
una relación proporcional
en este último ejemplo estos tres puntos
parecen ser la muestra de ye igual a x
al cuadrado la cual pasa por el origen
porque cuando x es igual a 0 y es igual
a 0 pero no es una relación lineal
entonces de cualquier forma que tú lo
veas una relación proporcional debe
cumplir que su gráfica debe ser una
línea que pasa por el origen y su tabla
analizando su tabla las razones deben
tener siempre el mismo valor lo cual
solamente fue el caso para este primer
ejemplo está sin fue una relación
proporcional